hello freak [ __ ] HuffPost had some
thing about pedophiles and they
eventually took it down I think but this
guy was saying I'm not a monster I'm a
pedophile and he's basically saying that
he has these thoughts he just doesn't
act on them and everybody was like what
oh god [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you would
they say that for everything right for
if you if you rape kids if you're a
child molester if you're a you know if
you shoot people it's a mental illness
Lester's are running this planet those
are you open the door [ __ ] those are the
rules you hear that Donald Trump's gonna
open up the JFK dump how about that all
the dump of documents from the JFK that
had been sealed up by all the other
presidents like the JFK assassination
investigation they sealed some documents
up because they're too sensitive and
like whatever I wasn't sir I wouldn't
they shred those documents no why would
damning documents be exists these are
people from 1962 also Trump for sure
focus on something else than this hey
this is not a bad thing to focus on if
you show me other things yeah for sure
but first of all no one really can be
President let's be honest there's not a
single person that could focus on the
economy in health care and international
relations and the environment and like
there's no way there's people to do a
job yes for sure but there's not enough
time in the world to focus on any of
those things
so nobody should focus on Donald Trump
should focus on the Vegas shooting he
hasn't said [ __ ] about well what do you
think you think there was such a [ __ ]
going on but here's the thing about this
this Kennedy assassination one of the
reasons why if I was him I would focus
on the Kennedy assassinations they might
[ __ ] kill him like it's entirely
possible that he's thinking that he
could get assassinated hundred percent
maybe that's why he's opening it if I
wasn't think there was any files like
why would they those files exist they
should have been burned a long time ago
yeah you would think so there's no file
and and also is it it it doesn't have
the high security of all time like they
they pay the most to protect him out of
all time cuz there's such a threat now
oh he has crazy security they see the
doors on his limo they they had a video
of him I was a
I can't stop coughing today I was going
I was looking at this image of him
there was a video of him getting out of
the limo and I was like look at that
door on that [ __ ] limo and then I
went to some images of the limo the limo
door is like that thick is it different
than Obama's though I don't know that
the standard one I don't have lack makes
I never looked at the other one but I
mean the doors are [ __ ] ridiculous
bomb-proof yeah yeah they're sick that
would be the dopest car to drive around
you be there sipping tea whatever is up
whole world yeah they make a car that
you can buy there's a company called dev
roll eau-de-vie rol oh and they make a
car like your truck a Toyota Tundra but
they make that [ __ ] bulletproof
I used to work for a company these two
bulletproof vehicles for two weeks it
was a fibre glad they do it fiberglass
I'm gonna hang yes I quit it was too
hard all the fiberglass fumes we shitty
gig we made cars for diplomats and
select mobile check cashing vans out
those are the big bangs mo license and
then private cars we just you just fill
the doors up with fiberglass just sheets
of fiberglass really yeah that's it
but what about the windows I don't know
windows are thick as [ __ ] it is
bulletproof it just bulletproof
underneath make it bomb-proof from
underneath mm-hmm fiberglass the [ __ ]
out of the doors
but this dev rollo company they do it
like consumer cars and I don't know what
they do with the wind in Brazil they're
popular bulletproof cars make sure hell
yeah update new Cadillac presidential
limousine to debut later in 2017
Cadillacs runs that [ __ ] got your assets
catalog called the beast America oh what
a [ __ ] clever name
to be the Beast you can't be cheap wait
a minute they're selling it to anybody
how come I can't borrow with the
president house come on bro
hmm what do you think how much one of
those limos goes for what's the money
say 600,000 no no no if the taxpayers
are paying for it that's 30 million its
that tax money hmm no bid contract a
billion dollar limousine two plus three
plus two layout means you can carry
chief executive and a couple of aides on
most journeys past your compartment
would still offer conference style
seating for five and the rear passenger
doors will still be positioned to the
front of the rear quarter windows that
will partially obscure the two rear
seats if I was president I wouldn't have
a chaotic like that something like that
but the front end be a Viper
I'm so American I'd have the Punisher
war van a [ __ ] white skull on the
side of it too
[Applause]
[Music]